foreign
[Music]
theater in Los Angeles in Beverly Hills
and we are giving a little concert with
some of my fellow musicians from Los
Angeles around the music of the French
dispatch that I wrote
it's sort of the central voice of your
score it is all over the yes all of us
going out here tonight because the
famous is in several sections and the
piano helps having some Sonic reference
sort of unifies the different sections
yep you can hear that the piano is
leading the the orchestra
some of the piano bars actually more
bluesy more American than French
can you talk about writing music for a
France that emerges from Wes's
imagination as opposed to the France
that you live in
yeah it's really a fantasized France
because it's a mix of duano and uh
[Music]
photograph photographers or directors of
the the 50s and 60s but it's mixed
through wess's eyes and Oasis memory
so it's it's not France it's something
else it's France from West as well
do you have a general philosophy about
film music what it needs to accomplish
for any movement yes try to avoid the
obvious try and start and stop at
different places let the actors breathe
and live their own moments but when the
music if it fits Creeps in or appears
you should feel the emotions
[Music]
grow
bigger but I think when you find the
right
balance between tune chords
instrumentation Rhythm then you can feel
that the music is is part of the film is
really dancing with as I said before
dancing with the actors and dancing with
it with the drama with the dramatology
the cinema is like staying in childhood
you know it takes you by the hand and
tells you a story and the music can can
terrifically emphasize that
[Music]
[Applause]
music from the French dispatch
help me thank our musicians film
independent our friends from Fox
Searchlight and especially Our Guest
Alexander display
foreign
[Music]